good morning american high
america a few years from now prosperous
clean and sober except one night a year
when all drugs and alcohol are
legal for you seniors you will be able
to participate in your first bench let's
say your name is kimberly jones and
let's say you binged
on a jet ski which exploded into flames
she's here tonight can you guys guess
which one she is
i'll give you a hint you're cold getting
warmer getting warmer red hot
burning hot she's the one that looks
like a mummy hmm
so it's been a badge after your dad's
speech i'm seriously thinking about it
me too by the way
this is our last chance to make a great
memory
tonight we become legends
[Applause]
hey everybody what's happening here
do you roofied our parents look we go to
that party you look leena in the eyes
and tell her exactly what you wanted to
tell her your entire life
ah let's go andrew here you guys cops
i have friends mom why don't you believe
me probably because your tendency
towards violence that's bad for the
church
i'll bury you behind a jiffy lube and my
friends are gonna help me we will not be
doing that
it's lena she just texts her from the
party she asks how long we're there tell
her we're picking up some presents it
autocorrected to i'm gonna get you
pregnant
[Music]
we'll give you a ride if you punch each
other in the face what
we'll do it one two
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
rumor has it that the girls are here
this is a little bit more of an adult
party
yeah and you're still wearing your pants
[Music]
to our first sip of alcohol
another round absolutely i'll have some
celery sticks
i really don't think we should be doing
this many drugs i don't think we to be
doing anyone red
that's you